que j'ai toujours considéré que
les manifestants quand ils font ça dans
dans le calme et comme ça a été la
plupart du temps dans les manifestations
sont complètement légitimes après ça
m'étonne pas non plus que et je crois
que ça a été bien expliqué que que la
baisse des moins de manifestants et des
cortèges moins importants des Français
11 points de plus que le 12 janvier à la
veille de la présentation de la réforme
et on doit en prendre comment nous le
groupe démocrate on demande que qui on a
on a saisi la main de Laurent Berger sur
la question d'une médiation et sur la
question de remettre un certain nombre
d'éléments sur la table
personnellement et le groupe démocrate
on pense que dans le texte tel qu'il est
vu qu'il y a cette fameuse clause de
voyeur dont on ne parle pas il y a
beaucoup de Français qui qui ont
peut-être oublié que c'est pas demain 64
ans l'âge de départ à la retraite c'est
progressif effectivement c'est septembre
pour ceux qui devaient partir ces trois
mois de plus et impactant et il faut en
prendre compte c'est évident mais c'est
progressif et en 2027 on sera à 63 ans
bon donc ça nous laisse quand même le
temps de mettre un certain nombre
d'éléments sur la table de travailler
sur les pénibilités ce travail sur les
carrières longues ou continuer à
travailler sur l'emploi des seniors il y
a des pistes il y a des travails de
remettre sur la table ce que vous nous
dites c'est que 63 ans 64 ans c'est pas
une fatalité en 2027 tout peut être
renégocié c'est ce que
politique c'est parce que je vous ai dit
ce que je vous ai dit c'est que il y a
des moyens la close d'or voyeur c'est de
se dire que il y a des possibilités si
on trouve des moyens de financement si
on trouve un équilibre de ce régime de
peut-être rester à 63 ans c'est pas pour
autre chose qu'on l'a fait juste vous
apprendre réponse quand même parce que
c'est important la démocratie c'est
c'est aussi
le choix d'un certain nombre de
personnes des députés à un moment donné
sur un programme et sur une
responsabilité et moi la responsabilité
que j'ai en tant que démocrate en tant
que député de notre pays c'est de faire
en sorte que le régime para répartition
continue à vivre moi l'équation elle est
simple il y a une équation simple c'est
pas de baisse des pensions pas de hausse
d'impôts
comment on fait alors
Adrien Clouet c'était la moitié de vos
amendements était pour créer des impôts
pour les financer ce régime donc vous
allez dessus vous mettez maintenant vous
admettez maintenant qu'il y a un
déséquilibre si vous voulez 13 milliards
mettez maintenant qu'il y avait un
déséquilibre on peut pas mettre d'un
côté on peut pas mettre de la pression
sur le Conseil constitutionnel
et lui reprocher qui serait politique
enfin le Conseil constitutionnel est un
organe et l'organe suprême de notre
Constitution c'est lui qui vise ou
invalide les processus constitutionnels
il se base sur le fond ensuite il y a
toujours et là je vous l'accorde quand
on fait du droit il y a toujours une
interprétation politique mais on ne peut
pas leur mettre la pression et leur et
dire qui serait légitime parce qu'ils
Invalides
et notamment la dangereux parce que ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que on
considère que le Conseil constitutionnel
ne sert plus à rien les conseils
constitutionnel il va dire oui non il va
dire un certain nombre de choses il va
retoquer une partie peut-être pas
peut-être l'ensemble du texte moi
j'avoue que je suis commissaire aux lois
je connais bien notre Constitution je
suis dans l'incapacité aujourd'hui de
vous dire est-ce que exactement ce qui
va décider j'ai une intuition sur un
certain nombre de sujets je pense qu'il
va valider le texte avec en retoquant et
en retoquant certains dispositifs et
aussi en mettant des réserves de
d'interprétation qui sont là pour le
coup extrêmement important aussi moi
j'aimerais
j'adorerais trouver l'intitulé du
référendum qui règle le conflit
et que effectivement mais vous voyez
bien comment
une fois qu'on a une fois qu'on a dit ça
comment on fait tout le reste du travail
et du financement vous voyez bien que ce
texte sur le texte qui a été débattu
donc dans le format 47-1 donc plfssr
donc
un budget social contraint dans le temps
il y a tout un nombre d'articles pour
régler un tout un tas de questions donc
tous ces questions là tranchées par
référendum c'est compliqué bon une fois
qu'on a dit ça moi je pense que
référendum accepté demain
j'y arrive la question la question pour
moi la question aujourd'hui c'est
comment on réconcilie les Français
comment on refait commun j'ai envie de
dire sur cette question comment on règle
des vrais sujets qui sont soulevés par
la CGT par la CFDT par la CFTC par tous
les syndicats sur la pénibilité les tant
de travail alors ça le Président il a
ouvert sa porte c'est nouveau de vous
recevoir il y a Laurent Berger qui parle
d'une grande conférence sociale moi je
pense que c'est la solution c'est la
solution avec en remettant sur la table
la question de l'âge d'une façon
peut-être par cette clause de revoyure
je le redis et on peut avancer comme ça
parce que il faut avancer on peut pas
rester dans un pays bloqué de cette
manière là parce qu'on a un certain
nombre d'enjeux à continuer à voir